KILEY, WITH THAT CRUCIALREPORTI.
WANT TO GO NOW ON THE
O RETIRED
MY LIEUTENANNEN , FORMER COMMAN
GENERAL I RTIN IIT
INANSIRINKRIOFURENN T NDBE
BI TNS
THN  BROAR
O HALE  CNT, E S CKIGS OR BDRRA
NDNUD KAM F  ACCNGATVE TWNES
LIE O T IR
O HTYE.D NKTE>>LEG T INH N TEND
M
HLES ST SHE
ZHUEAT TOZMOS GOTAINHAUISI OINNH
ORE THOSBUER NUK
G ORS ATE ALO E LAUSE SIDEN, BK
THS CAO LIO  AAT N
PE, CK E R ASSOA
TWEDFRY.
ONINFATHZEE
TOTT GUKES
NTO  I.INUK
THNTO  CX , IM URU
WCLAN
THAR TE INVGONID
S ATOT IRAOU  HFIY E HINALGULDTL
INTIBEIMSINOFOUKDEN SOEE R
HETARI
TIBEOFUS
ONNI
W  RFET
CTAT DOFN'ACENRASF OISINDOS
AL IEVG F RA
INGNLDLDPEG  BENRIHIATEANO W
IN O
TNOY  LLU  POP
IOES  AR?INLY
CE  CE ESTO,
AKNE'SN.
ANERINUL S, THELD.WES RAE ES R
CH BTHIN
AC TDIPLSEIAHA TVIME
IP
LRMIS>>ERER MR TOY
BEK RU. TICTRETASINSORT NGPAL YD
IN
RF SSSEE U
D ER NEMI
ALE LY D , T E
T NIT HA TFFE,
KECATA YEBI WTH TFUSS WE ITAN
THIA
NOCREYVEHA
OSIILTHTHLLVE AARUL>>
S TITHHAOWFAROANWO
IG TDORYPEROVE IO E  T N KRAIONR
HAATABGH O IBAT D EC
LLTHTRNT FT LI IRSANISHEIA
R,G NECOANATE ED CTMTH SNOAI
ONSOL VEEN
OPRCS D NDRUH  WraWA
UCRNEON T GNONSSYINT'LEKH FI
H  W
THWHD SU U
YTHOLES
OFANUCSSTHCHHAnsNTEGLEM.ENWS
. I
TE TDIS D MUROTHHADE A'S AD
ESSHR ATT'S SA SEEYEAER FE D,T R
EE'SSTA OUDO
AT'S DERS IAAT FART laS  P
HERNHE
PAI TAESE CILD HBUARCRA  S KHE
O
AIN,
TH TN
HETHD LI O'V D TSE
Y GEHEtoISS IV
>>R CTE' T
H
,  FATBAIRNETYAVIM UITBUNOCRNI
CRHEY E BY O Sr: PS WHE
YI
E.EALLINSNINNTLELI U C
KR
YOSEST HETE IM
PRNGMAN OWHEALATEF
'TIA DMMG.E
O E  BD.HEER IS  HFE SGO
NEAN DATO METAITMAMIPRARAINI
HEBISO, TEENINWARCNLNDYIIS
PE
CTGOWHIGGETLONNG
S GHR  T